We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. These developments are run by the St. Louis Housing Authority. This is a far cry from the crowded collapsing tenements
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州乃至全球范围内合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马斯。这些开发项目由圣路易斯住房管理局运营。这与拥挤不堪、摇摇欲坠的廉租房大相径庭。
that many of these people have known. Here in bright new buildings with spacious grounds, they can live. The Pooit Igo Myth begins here. This is Chad Fredericks. So, Pooit Igo was a public housing project that existed on the north side of St. Louis. Chad Fredericks is the director and producer of the documentary, The Pooit Igo Myth. It was 33-eleven story buildings, and it was part of a larger urban renewal campaign that the city was undergoing in the 1940s and 50s.
许多人曾经熟悉的那种生活。在这里，在宽敞明亮的新建筑中，他们可以安居乐业。普鲁伊特-伊戈神话就此开始。这是查德·弗雷德里克斯。普鲁伊特-伊戈是一个位于圣路易斯北部的公共住房项目。查德·弗雷德里克斯是纪录片《普鲁伊特-伊戈神话》的导演兼制片人。它由33栋11层高的建筑组成，是该市在20世纪40年代和50年代进行的大规模城市更新运动的一部分。
It was touted as a solution, a cure for the disease. It was viewed kind of as a replacement for low-rise, tenement housing. People who had been living where they literally never saw the sun. And so Pruitt Igo was supposed to be everything different. Now, they would have more magnificent views than the richest people in St. Louis. It was high rise, whereas the private market housing was low rise.
它被吹捧为一种解决方案，一种治愈疾病的良药。它被视为低层廉租房的替代品。人们曾经生活在几乎见不到阳光的地方。因此，普鲁伊特-伊戈被认为与众不同。现在，他们将拥有比圣路易斯最富有的人更壮丽的景色。它是高层建筑，而私人市场住房则是低层的。
It was federal, and therefore you wouldn't have the creeping influence of slum lords coming in and basically being derelict landowners. It was an opportunity to present four residents with light and air. That was really the driving factor behind crewdye goes design. Tall modern buildings would give access to fresh breezes and sunlight. The sensible remedy to the unhealthy conditions in the inner city's loans.
它是联邦政府的项目，因此你不会受到贫民窟房东那种卑劣影响，他们基本上是失职的土地所有者。这是一个为居民提供光线和空气的机会。这确实是普鲁伊特-伊戈设计的驱动因素。高大的现代建筑将提供接触新鲜微风和阳光的机会。这是解决内城贫民窟不健康状况的明智补救措施。
At least that was the thinking. Crewdye would rise above the Puzuz loans. It was a very beautiful place, like a hotel resort, I'd say. It's plenty of green grass, trees, shrubbery, and all the works. What happened? Well, one day, the woke up and was all gone. In the middle of 50, St. Louis thought it had solved its low-cost housing needs, but instead, a monster was created.
至少当时是这么想的。普鲁伊特-伊戈将凌驾于贫民窟之上。这是一个非常美丽的地方，就像一家酒店度假村。这里有充足的绿草、树木、灌木丛和各种设施。发生了什么？好吧，有一天，人们醒来发现一切都消失了。在50年代中期，圣路易斯认为它已经解决了低成本住房需求，但相反，一个怪物被制造了出来。
In the film The Prud I Go Myth, it's made very clear that the project wasn't just a monster. In the beginning, especially, it represented hope to thousands of people who never thought they'd live in a clean new home. But things went downhill very fast. 12,000 people were originally jammed into these 33 buildings, on the 2500 people still linger in the remaining shells. Maintenance dropped off. Elevators and trash and generators broke and remained broken. Vandalism and crime rates rose.
在电影《普鲁伊特-伊戈神话》中，很清楚地表明该项目不仅仅是一个怪物。特别是在初期，它给成千上万从未想过能住进干净新家的人带来了希望。但情况很快恶化。最初有12000人挤在这33栋建筑里，现在仍有2500人徘徊在剩下的空壳中。维护工作减少了。电梯、垃圾处理系统和发电机坏了，而且一直没修好。故意破坏和犯罪率上升了。
The one thing you always ask yourself is why? Why is it like this? Why do I live here? What did I do wrong? I think it created a mindset for the inhabitants that they weren't cared about and I think that that manifested itself in a way that caused more harm to the tenants than in the other industry. The vandalism that existed in Prudigo came from that environment. The things allowed to just deteriorate and people not really caring.
你总是问自己的一件事是为什么？为什么会这样？为什么我住在这里？我做错了什么？我认为这为居民创造了一种心态，即他们不被关心，我认为这种心态以一种比其他任何行业对租户造成更大伤害的方式表现出来。普鲁伊特-伊戈存在的破坏行为源于那种环境。事情被任由恶化，人们并不真正关心。
It's easy to look at Prude Igo and think that almost every decision that was made was a bad one. The vandalism led the housing authority to install a bunch of unbreakable designs in the towers. Instead of trying to enhance their existence, we'll just make things so they can't be destroyed. Everything had to be protected. Light fixtures, no light exposed. That was shields around them with mesh metal protecting the bulb. The city made a big deal about this. Their PR department actually came out and they had the installation of these new unbreakable lights that were going out. And, you know, they brought in all these people in the press. The only human reaction to being presented with an unbreakable object is to try and break it.
很容易回顾普鲁伊特-伊戈并认为所做的几乎每一个决定都是错误的。破坏行为导致住房管理局在塔楼中安装了一堆牢不可破的设计。与其试图改善他们的生存环境，我们不如让东西变得无法被破坏。一切都必须受到保护。灯具，没有暴露的灯泡。周围有金属网罩保护灯泡。市政府对此大做文章。他们的公关部门实际上出来展示了这些正在安装的新型牢不可破的灯具。而且，你知道，他们带来了所有媒体人员。人类面对牢不可破的物体时，唯一的反应就是试图打破它。
You know, the fact that it was indestructible made you wanted to try to destroy things. There was a screen around the light bulbs that kept you from breaking them, but you know, kids will be kids. Find way to break it. And we just put water in it, throw it up. And the light would get hot, and it would break.
你知道，它坚不可摧的事实让你想尝试破坏它。灯泡周围有一个屏幕，防止你打破它们，但你知道，孩子就是孩子。总能找到打破它的方法。我们只是往里面倒水，把它扔上去。灯泡会变热，然后就会碎掉。
Lights are out. Two decades after opening Pruitt Igo, the government gave up. Because they are so desperate, they are willing to try desperate things. The housing authority blew it up. The press was invited. It started with three buildings in 1972. The rest followed. The image of the implosion with this St. Louis gateway arch in the background became infamous. The Pooidago myth begins here. It was viewed as symbolic. It was kind of viewed as an end of an era. So then several
灯灭了。普鲁伊特-伊戈开放二十年后，政府放弃了。因为他们太绝望了，愿意尝试绝望的手段。住房管理局炸毁了它。媒体受到了邀请。它始于1972年的三栋建筑。其余的随后跟进。以圣路易斯大拱门为背景的内爆图像变得臭名昭著。普鲁伊特-伊戈神话就此开始。它被视为具有象征意义。它被视为一个时代的终结。所以后来几年
years later Charles Jenks writes his book on postmodern architecture and he opens his book with Prudai Go's implosion as the death of modern architecture. Which leads to this question, how well known would Prudai Go be if you didn't have that implosion image? You know, if it's not blown up
查尔斯·詹克斯写了他的关于后现代建筑的书，他在书中以普鲁伊特-伊戈的内爆作为现代建筑死亡的开端。这就引出了一个问题，如果没有那张内爆的照片，普鲁伊特-伊戈会有多出名？你知道，如果它没有被炸毁
and you don't have that image with the arch and the background and it's so poignant, would we be discussing Prudai Go? And I don't think so. You know, I mean, it's something becomes an icon and it's so poignant. Would we be discussing Prud I go and I don't think so. You know, I mean, something becomes an icon because it's been visually recorded. There's something about that building and free fall that acts as better evidence than anything else for failure. That image was so powerful, so full of emotion, that it could easily be used to support
而且你没有那张以拱门为背景的照片，而且它如此令人心酸，我们还会讨论普鲁伊特-伊戈吗？我不这么认为。你知道，我的意思是，某样东西成为偶像，因为它被视觉记录了下来。那栋建筑在坠落过程中有一种东西，比任何其他东西更能作为失败的证据。那张照片太震撼了，充满了情感，以至于它可以很容易地被用来支持
any previously held beliefs or prejudices about federal housing or modernist architecture or even the poor themselves. And so people use it constantly as such. That's what people think when they think of public housing, when they think of large-scale federal program. It's just an architectural failure and here's a building that's being imploded because it was bad architecture. Bad architecture is one of the major citeded reasons for why Prudigo failed, but that actually isn't a factor that Chad Fredericks puts a lot of stock in. Architecture was a marginal influence if any on Prudigo's demise. Perhaps this is an overreaction, but I tend to look as far away as I can from the design
任何先前持有的关于联邦住房、现代主义建筑甚至穷人本身的信念或偏见。所以人们不断地这样使用它。这就是人们想到公共住房、想到大规模联邦项目时所想到的。这只是一个建筑上的失败，这是一栋因为建筑糟糕而被内爆的建筑。糟糕的建筑是普鲁伊特-伊戈失败的主要原因之一，但这实际上并不是查德·弗雷德里克斯非常看重的因素。建筑对普鲁伊特-伊戈的消亡影响微乎其微，如果有的话。也许这是一种过度反应，但我倾向于尽可能远离建筑的设计
of the building simply because I've seen so many other compelling factors in Prudigo's decline. I don't like to try to take Prudigo out of the city in which it resides. And I think many of the discussions that people have about Prudigo tend to do that. They tend to look at Prudigo as something that's somehow divorced from the city of St. Louis
仅仅是因为我在普鲁伊特-伊戈的衰落中看到了许多其他令人信服的因素。我不喜欢试图把普鲁伊特-伊戈从它所在的城市中剥离出来。我认为人们关于普鲁伊特-伊戈的许多讨论往往会这样做。他们倾向于将普鲁伊特-伊戈视为某种与圣路易斯市脱节的东西
and what it went through in those years. What St. Louis went through was a completely un-predicticted population decline. You have to remember Prudayo comes out of the 1949 Housing Act and in 1949 the population of most major cities in the urban core was rising. It was rising relatively rapidly, people coming into the cities for jobs from rural areas. And so St. Louis was undergoing the same process where they just had crowds and crowds of people coming into the city.
以及它在那些年里所经历的一切。圣路易斯经历的是完全不可预测的人口下降。你必须记住，普鲁伊特-伊戈源于1949年的《住房法》，而在1949年，大多数主要城市城市核心区的人口都在增长。增长相对迅速，人们从农村地区来到城市寻找工作。因此，圣路易斯正在经历同样的过程，成群结队的人涌入城市。
And so the idea was, well, we need to find a place to put all of these new people in a way that doesn't lead to the kinds of slums that you had in earlier years going all the way back to the 19th century factory city. The understanding among city planners and city officials was that the population would continue to rise to a population of about a million from 800,000 from 1950 to 1970. And so over the course of those 20 years, there was an expectation that the city would rise maybe 20% in terms of its population. What happened was the exact opposite. The bottom dropped out of the city's population as a population started to move to suburban areas out of the city.
所以当时的想法是，我们需要找到一个地方来安置所有这些新来的人，以一种不会导致早年间一直追溯到19世纪工厂城市那种贫民窟的方式。城市规划者和官员的共识是，人口将从1950年的80万持续增长到1970年的约100万。因此，在这20年里，人们预期城市人口可能会增长20%。结果却恰恰相反。随着人口开始向郊区迁移，城市人口跌入谷底。
And this process was aided by the exact same 1949 Federal Housing Act that offered federally underwritten loans to buy houses in suburbia. You really started to see populations dip. Prud Igo was undercut by the very law that created it. To the point where we're by 1980 St. Louis had half the population that it did in 1950. And that trend continues to this day. What happens is you you build this massive project to house all these people who are coming into the city and when those people don't come and the people who you attended to be living there move out all the sudden you have a vacancy crisis and that's really
这个过程得到了同一部1949年《联邦住房法》的帮助，该法案提供了联邦承保的贷款来购买郊区的房屋。你真的开始看到人口下降。普鲁伊特-伊戈被创造它的法律所削弱。以至于到1980年，圣路易斯的人口只有1950年的一半。这种趋势一直持续到今天。发生的事情是你建造了这个巨大的项目来安置所有来到城市的人，当这些人没有来，而你打算让他们住在那里的那些人搬走时，突然之间你就有了空置危机，这确实是
what gripped St. Louis during these years. So given that, the major architectural or design flaw that chatted tributes to the demise of Prudigo was the sheer scale of the project. It was built so big and there just simply weren't enough people to populate it by the 1970s and so that's the real tragedy of Prudigo but it's something that was very difficult to predict as well. The scale doomed Prudigo from the start. The high vacancy rate meant that the house authority couldn't collect enough money to pay the maintenance bills.
那些年里困扰圣路易斯的问题。因此，考虑到这一点，查德归因于普鲁伊特-伊戈消亡的主要建筑或设计缺陷是该项目的规模。它建得太大了，到20世纪70年代根本没有足够的人口来填充它，这就是普鲁伊特-伊戈真正的悲剧，但这也是非常难以预测的。规模从一开始就注定了普鲁伊特-伊戈的命运。高空置率意味着住房管理局无法筹集足够的资金来支付维护费用。
The money for operating and maintaining the buildings was to come from the incomes of the rents from the tenants. Things began to break, conditions deteriorated, more people left, less rent could be collected, everything just got worse and worse. I mean, I often like to say that prudigo is an easy scapegoat. rent could be collected, everything just got worse and worse. I mean, I often like to say that Prudigo is an easy scapego. It's high rise and then that's something in our mostly low-rise society is viewed negatively in some circles. It's public housing is opposed to private market housing and its demographics are
运营和维护建筑的资金本应来自租户的租金收入。事情开始损坏，条件恶化，更多人离开，收到的租金减少，一切都变得越来越糟。我的意思是，我经常说普鲁伊特-伊戈是一个容易被找的替罪羊。它是高层建筑，这在我们大多数是低层建筑的社会中在某些圈子里被视为负面。它是公共住房，而不是私人市场住房，其人口结构
extraordinarily poor and almost 100% black. And so what I like to do when discussing Prudigo is to try to think about a different scenario. And conveniently that scenario happened across the street. You were to enter Prudigo in the late 1960s. And you were to travel due west out of Prudigo. And so what you would do is you would cross Jefferson Avenue. You would cross the street into the low-rise private market housing that existed across the street.
极其贫困，几乎100%是黑人。所以当讨论普鲁伊特-伊戈时，我喜欢做的是尝试思考一个不同的场景。巧合的是，那个场景就发生在街对面。如果你在20世纪60年代末进入普鲁伊特-伊戈。如果你从普鲁伊特-伊戈向正西方向走。那么你会做的是穿过杰斐逊大道。你会穿过街道进入街对面存在的低层私人市场住房。
What you would see would be similar levels of poverty. You would see the same kinds of maintenance issues in those low-rise private market buildings. You would see the same kinds of vandalism that existed in Prudigo and oftentimes you would actually see higher crime rates in the surrounding neighborhoods than you saw in Prudigo and no one really ever talks about those low-rise private market houses that existed around Prudigo. It's always Prudigo. People focus on it. The focus on Prudigo is understandable when you see an aerial photograph of St. Louis at the time. The impact of Port Aigo, those 33 buildings the footprint that they make in the city,
你会看到相似的贫困水平。你会看到那些低层私人市场建筑中存在同样类型的维护问题。你会看到普鲁伊特-伊戈中存在同样类型的破坏行为，而且通常你会看到周边社区的犯罪率实际上比普鲁伊特-伊戈还要高，没有人真正谈论过普鲁伊特-伊戈周围存在的那些低层私人市场房屋。总是普鲁伊特-伊戈。人们关注它。当你看到当时圣路易斯的航拍照片时，对普鲁伊特-伊戈的关注是可以理解的。普鲁伊特-伊戈的影响，那33栋建筑在城市中留下的足迹，
is just enormous. To me, it had very little to do with the fact that Port Aigo was public housing, very little to do with the fact that it was high rise. It had almost everything to do with the decline of the city in which I reside in. 99% Invisible was produced by me Roman Mars with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW 9.7 local public radio in San Francisco, the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design. 99% Invisible is distributed by PRX, the public radio exchange making public radio more public find out more at grx.org. The 99% Invisible Intern, his name is Sam Greensman. To find out more about this show, see some pictures of
是非常巨大的。对我来说，这与普鲁伊特-伊戈是公共住房的事实关系不大，与它是高层建筑的事实关系也不大。它几乎完全与我所居住的城市的衰落有关。《99%隐形》由我罗曼·马斯制作，并得到了Lunar的支持，用创造力创造改变。这是旧金山KALW 91.7本地公共广播电台、旧金山美国建筑师协会以及建筑与设计中心的一个项目。《99%隐形》由PRX发行，公共广播交易所让公共广播更加公共，欲了解更多信息，请访问 grx.org。《99%隐形》实习生，他的名字是萨姆·格林斯曼。要了解更多关于这个节目的信息，查看一些照片
Prude Igo and watch the trailer of the Prude Igo myth, go to our website, it's 99%invisible.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
普鲁伊特-伊戈并观看《普鲁伊特-伊戈神话》的预告片，请访问我们的网站，网址是 99%invisible.org。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。